[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté vous n'allez pas me dire que vous
avez l'intention de faire une omelette
avec cela et comment était le regrette
mais quel jeu surtout c'est bruce a oui
ce que vous verrez ça c'est en france si
ici en gironde à grignols par web ici
j'ai peine à boucler on ira les voir
toutes les deux qu'est ce que c'est des
oeufs d'autruche moi le truc je croyais
que c'était en australie ou en afrique
du sud
eh bien non maintenant on les a bien
acclimaté havre france et réussi ce très
très bien et puis combien temps que peu
de temps bien plus longtemps
il ya pas longtemps y'a pas longtemps
quand il gèle doivent avoir bien peur
les personnages rit parce qu'elle dorme
dehors et tours eh bien ça dort dehors
et voyez cet homme sa crème va tellement
le froid ça se dirait bien adaptés oui
mais ne faisons pas le net revenant
bon et alors l'autruche alors l'autre on
ne sait pas que l'omelette avec six noms
alors l'autruche regardez-moi ça cet
animal comme ses parents j'ai toujours
un petit l ébène avant de refaire un
coup farcir est en émoi la longue non
pas de mauvaises pensées mais là tu es
arabe et après on peut se servir de la
grèce vient mambo la grèce d'autruche
c'est pour faire des produits de beauté
ça protège du soleil et c'est efficace
et puis après regardez moi alors là bien
ma chérie via ma chérie regardez moi ces
cuisses haut que ça la regarde et montre
au collet billon
elle se voit là regardez moi ça et puis
après il ya la peau on peut faire des
sacs à main de 25 ans vise y aller
frimer un truc à bin oui c'est très très
très bon alors les plus gros fai des
éventails
on faisait des éventails et que je lis
les cuissots vous faites donc et badji
globalement ses pattes que ça regardez
ça c'est superbe
vous savez qui paraît qu'on peut les
montées comme des jours on s'accroche
aux ailes moi je veux pas y aller il est
un peu et puis alors ici à la russie un
petit bébé le bébé qui a deux mois
ce bébé magnifique et puis cabinet
regarder les yeux vous avez vu les
autruches et bien ce bébé il a quand
même un kilo il pèse 1 kg 200 à 900
grammes stable depuis menu ce genre a
mal à la naissance
il regarde bien voir il vient à petit
l'idée là
il est très intimidé le pauvre on la
regarde mon bébé quant à l'élève tous un
petit peu de moi regarder si c'est beau
ah ça y est voilà on ne veut pas là ça y
est voilà vont me b regardez comme c'est
joli c'est joli c'est magnifique
je crois que vous racontez que dans cet
élevage de grignols on ne va pas les
bêtes cela vive le coup parce qu'ils
font des recherches dans génétique et
ils font la reproduction simple parce
que commence en france à la réceptionner
des rats après ça on verra ce qu'on en
fait alors nous aujourd'hui et bien par
ailleurs on a pu avoir un peu de viande
d'autruche et regardez moi cette ville
que voulez vous on dirait du boeuf on
dirait une vient de de beurre et
pourtant la viande d'oiseau on croit
rêver mais c'est possible quand même un
oiseau la preuve parce que regarder et
j'en ai mangé c'est succulent septembre
c'est du beurre est là aujourd'hui on va
là on peut cuisiner 2008 de façon à pouy
36 recettes on peut en faire tant qu'on
veut des recettes c'est comme le boeuf
est là aujourd'hui on va faire des tares
des tournedos d'autruche aux morilles
j'ai hâte de voir comment vous allez
faire ça il le goût ksar excellent
comment faites-vous a alors l'âge la
viande comme ça comme un jolie tourne
dos voilà la halle alerte en train elle
a pas l'air et l'année alors je veux
sauver l'affairé cuivre au beurre il
faut le saisir la réforme beurre bien
chauvière chaud mais pas brûler quand
même et votre poids la dernière clergeau
d'une avarie très chic très bien alors
je mets mon steak c'est très difficile
le très très très il faut bien garder à
l'arrêt voilà il faut leur tournée bien
saisi des deux côtés il saisit pas dax a
fini de cuir je vais mettre de beurre à
notre poids assez compliqué j'espère que
vous suivez parce que vous faire un truc
comme ça c'est pas donné à tout le monde
voilà je prends des horribles à tout
point de vue
la pauvre texte pas exagérer quand même
noter pour terminer vous économisez
parce que c'est rare et c'est cher ce
veuves et les salles et les pauvres est
bien entendu au parc le feu est trop
forte quand même tu es là n'ont été
accusés quand même oui à rue colbert à
noircir la ici avoue aimer ça obligé par
m
voilà alors là je vais déglacer avec du
porto je vous le donne
loana parce que les bories sur des
activités
voilà et on va laisser réduire ce petit
soft
pendant ce temps le steak il faut que ce
soit très ouverte avec de vous je
m'arrête insultant et le pp oui on va le
tenir au chaud à l'entrée du tour a
mariné du four là et pendant que ça
réveille on peut peut-être faire un
autre steak alors à ce moment-là au
progrès la crème steak au poivre vert
alors voilà que cet enfant thème qu'est
ce qu'il vous faut
pas grand chose un petit peu de vin
blanc du pauvre vert de la crème fraîche
et du banc pour le pire et évidemment le
steak d'autruche
alors comment l'avez-vous alors j'ai mis
le beurre je mets la poêle chauffez j'ai
mis du beurre dans la poêle bien entendu
la poêle chaude parce qu'il faut que le
maire soit le steak soir si un séisme
alors stop voilà en mai on fait une
cuisine d'aujourd'hui est électeur d'une
sàrl et c'est très compliqué d'elle
poivre sel poivre
on tourne oui voilà il faut que nous
l'avions doit être très saignante
les mavs et on a été un peu aidé
heureusement dans cette affaire il faut
bien dire par nos amis de la cave à
jublains vos amis de laquelle va jusque
là les seuls à bordeaux actuellement qui
ont à la carte
mais le plat avec de la chabotterie ch y
en a aussi à paris mais à bordeaux ils
sont légion dans le dos alors je
voudrais là c'est un peu micheline déjà
bien sûr le steak
il est cuit la stoppe là leur côté jeu
des glaces avec un petit peu de vin
blanc
après la peine et peut ensuite je mets
le nez voire wavre dans des marches mais
il faut quand même c'est donc vendredi
la crème fraîche ancêtres et profitez-en
c'est de la cuisine très sophistiqué
qu'aujourd'hui
et je mélange tout ça et ça va épaissir
hélas les morilles regarder comme ça
vous allez remettre un petit peu de
crème aussi donc quand vous voilà
remettre aussi pas mal ça ça va épaissir
on va sortir au steak grillé genre de
final entre air le four c'est un
tournedos pas un steak qui est très
élevé
d'autres ardoin pardon pardon là
regardez moi ça c'est joli mais je crois
surtout que ce sera beau saalous
extraordinaire voilà ceci c'est
pratiquement fait et c'est vite fait mal
on n'a pas tout si je vais napper mon
steak tout simplement l'autre vous
voulez donner le trouvera le tournedos
qui se trouvent ici je vais vous le
donner lorient est bien joli de ce côté
là il est super beau m voilà alors
aujourd'hui on a pas on n'a pas bricoler
l'oeil et à la rame qui joue dessus
aussi
on va le mettre dans ces bons quand même
c'est de la cuisine facile n'a été
lancée fait quand on arrive de
travailler c'est rien alors ça regardez
moi ça à voir maintenant de l'île
maurice le porto la crème et voilà et
c'est terminé on a une troisième manière
de la faire cette autruches
oui on va faire interpack utah fatiou
d'autruche avec un peu de basilic je
crois oui et ça va être délicieux et
savait tout faire il faut couper très
très faim mais attention à la peau de
vote
non non non non mais c'est bien vous
croyez au rendez vous alors vous me
donnez l'assiette
oui parce que j'en ai déjà pas mal coupé
regardez-moi ça c'est bon c'est de
garder des cobras ça vous impressionne
moins que d'autres invités de tout à
l'heure il ya le bébé maman voilà papa
le simple en pommes de terre le corps
avec une morille et la tête je sais trop
un effet 12 où il ya s'amusent comme des
petits fous
voilà alors je vais saler poivrer
un petit peu
parce que le carpaccio bien entendu on
cesse accrue oui alors ici dedans je
vais mettre de l'huile d'olive un petit
peu du duo lives un petit peu de vin
blanc sec
celui que vous voudrez je vais saler
poivrer encore ah oui ça sera pas trop
en maintenant parce que là la sauce m je
vais remuer et puis une goutte de citron
vert
oui mais alors il faut pas mettre
beaucoup pour la bonne raison que ça
dure si la viande d'autruche qui s'y
trouvent et voilà c'est ce qu'ils ont
dans lequel on fait et qui ont prouvé ça
mais vous savez du buteur dans le top 3
août c'est bon et alors là je vais y
mettre un petit peu de basilic que je
vais lâcher ça sent bon ce basilique
comme ça tout frais oui mais ça c'est
facile parce qu'on peut la voir sur
impôts oui sur les fenêtres vous envoyer
leurs terrasses vont envoyer parce qu'à
bordeaux on dit que ça empêche les
moustiques d'entrée par tout l'été sur
les ménages tout le monde en mer voilà
c'est pas pour ça c'était facile à faire
là et bien on va le mettre tout
simplement là dessus et j'ai maintenant
combien de temps un tout petit peu quand
même reprendre l'avion à auxerre minutes
pas plus
voilà mais on a peut-être le temple est
encore une recette puisque on a la
chance d'avoir cette jolie viande
d'autruche
on va faire du un tournedos ou
inspectent comme on veut au sauternes
mêmes méthodes que prescilla nantes
pareil
un petit peu de sel et de poivre
on tourne parce qu'il faut être à 100 et
je vous fasse assiette
alors on ne va pas partir très vite ma
vie là alors voilà là vous me donnez et
maintenant vous allez les gars assis
avec un malheureux en faut perdre ce
qu'on veut
ainsi à côté et voilà la ce a permis la
fin de journée peut-être devant notaire
de gestes berne ce qui ne gâche rien du
tout et parce que ça ne devrait jamais
artisanales que nous pouvons et que tout
le monde vend de la recette là l'adresse
info non labeaume est en jeu ça y est il
y en a alors est un peu de crème fraîche
et voilà et c'est tout et ça vous savez
aujourd'hui c'est la cuisine facile et
de fête
ça y est c'est fait un deux minutes
alors cuisine facile cuisine rapide mais
une grande première quand même puisque
nous avons eu une autruche sur le
plateau voire la hat est magnifique
voilà et bien si vous avez envie d'en
faire autant demandez à votre boucher
s'il peut commencer à vous trouver de la
viande d'autruche puisqu'on en élève en
france et en tout cas à bientôt
bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]